- Ah!
(laughing)
It's so bad!
(metal music)
- What the fuck!
- So, we're gonna play a game
that has something to do with spicy stuff.
(metal music)
- It's an Oreo.
- Oh no, I don't like this.
- No, no, I don't know about this.
(laughing)
- So sure I got it.
- This is cruel and unusual.
- I'm so sure I got it!
- Mine's normal.
- Normal!
- Oh, you got it?
(laughter)
- I'm good.
- Oh!
- Are you okay?
- I knew it, I knew it you fuckers!
- I kinda dig that combo.
- Good?
- Yeah.
- How spicy are we getting?
(metal music)
- I'm scared.
There's a lot of adrenaline
coursing through me.
- Okay, sushi?
- I don't feel like eating sushi.
- Alright, so there's avocado sushi
that's been placed in front of us,
which only means one thing.
Wasabi.
- I'm gonna wait until you guys --
Oh, you got it, yes!
- I fucking got it again.
(laughing)
- My freaking tongue is on fire!
- Oh my God, my mouth is burning,
I need milk.
(metal music)
- I don't love this.
- This is tricky.
- I know.
- Oh, fuck, you took my guy.
(laughing)
- Okay, I'm doing it.
- Commit!
- I think it's normal.
(laughing)
Yes!
- Fuck.
(crying)
- Ah!
- It's really great seeing
your face like this,
because that was my face two times.
How does it feel?
Yeah.
- My heart's beating really fast,
and I'm really lightheaded.
(intense bass)
- Fuck, dude.
- Yours is fudged, I think.
Oh wait, no.
- I think I'm good.
- Fuck!
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- Fuck you.
- Oh, this is --
- Woo!
- It's burning as it goes.
- I took a little sip, and it was like --
- Oh, girl, I chugged that shit.
- Ugh.
- Never doing this again.
- I'm not replying to your e-mails.
- I'm already not
thrilled about the farts.
- Poop's gonna burn tonight.
- Spicy asshole.
- You guys never get spicy asshole?
- Yeah, I get it all the fucking time.
- Yeah, spicy asshole's a thing.